the Joe Rogan experience what you think
kind of gonna do whatever he wants
probably do a lot of coke you know
what's crazy before I was kid and I
before I ever he's gonna have some fun
man I think if he finds a fight that's
fun he's got a hundred million dollars
in the bank if he finds a fight that's
fun
he's gonna do it but the problem with
him is it mean they wanted him to do
cowboy and there was some talk about him
doing a cowboy fight but he wanted to be
a main event the UFC wants main events
to all be big time championship anything
kind of do is big that's what I said but
they think that somehow another having
no championship title online I would
love to spin a day in a life with Dana
White well Justin gate you don't think
so conflict of interest yeah cuz he's
got their own thing that UFC invest
sucks cuz I really want to do too
Anatomy or Dana why just hanging out
with him for a baby who knows my Randy
would help embedded and maybe it would
help the Tuesday night contender series
it would help pump that up air gal
Barris has said the perfect thing he
said why would the UFC be worried about
you you like a lemonade stand in a
coca-cola well I think that way but some
people don't some people don't want to
help other things get going but I'm
promoting them what if you stop
promoting them and just really
concentrating a Bellator and the channel
is gigantic now because you did so much
UFC contests true that's how people look
at things well you know my first idea
was to tell the UFC let me just film all
the fighters y'all not gonna promote
this fight week so embed it is 10 of the
fighters letting Adam unify to get them
give me a credential and let me just
filming them all week so I'm around film
these fighters that y'all never gonna
post what did they say about that not
interesting never nah I didn't get a not
interested button oh no it's what it's
weird because I much love to the UFC
because they give me a lot of access and
I love every single person over there
like being Klein and Heidi D all those
people I love them they treat me like a
knowing cousin they're great people I'm
annoying cousin when I'm a fighter and
that's that they I haven't been to a lot
of fight weeks but it seems like people
think I'll go to every fight weekend
it's like I only go to ones I can afford
or they make sense like if I had the
funds I'd be at every fight week filming
are you gonna be in Vegas for the John
Jones choco Santos yeah because
I'm nominated for a ward against you oh
really for what the world MMA awards
what's a best MMA programming i what am
world MMA awards are GRE MMA show yep
now you're on it so is that I know
that's so weird that is so well I told
you confessions of an online dater first
on what the way I thought I was gonna
end up on well I hope you win
I won a bunch of those it's me you never
go is me you embed it Dana why scan
Tuesday can see contender series and in
a MMA hour but I hope you win against me
how about that that'd be a that'd be I
smoke weed if I did like I'm doing I'm
done
[Applause]